Westworld season 3 explores a new world
the robot Dolores has escaped the
west-world Park and enters the real
human world in a year 2058 this season's
almost like a reboot with a new setting
new characters and new style but with
the same themes of Technology freedom
and control it's also got death grips
now the premiere begins with a beach
just like season two begins on a beach
and season 1 ends on a beach
Teddy once said that weather mountains
meet the sea the waters will wash the
past off you so you can start again
West world is washing away the chaos of
season 2 and starting a new story in a
new world or maybe it's just a [ __ ]
beach Jerry is a rich guy in a Chinese
mansion he's angry because he's an
investor in the West World parks and
news just broke that a hundred people
died in the parks
when Dolores and the hosts went on a
rampage last season jerry is rude and
controlling to his wife Eunice so Jerry
is instantly dislikable we see
futuristic technology like there are
Holograms you can see with special
glasses and there are hi-tech drugs
called limbic tabs people have implants
on the roof of their mouth and when you
put in a tab it sends a digital code to
your brain to change your mood the
west-world website says available
flavors include Zen garden a gender
achiever and impulse Jerry's mansion has
smart home technology like an Alexa
robot voice that controls the place this
whole human world is run by machines
which makes it vulnerable to machines
like Dolores Dolores comes in the night
and hacks the smart home system turning
off the oxygen to knock everyone out
Jerry tries to get help and the system
says I'm afraid I can't do that which is
what Hal 9000 says in 2001 a Space
Odyssey
Dolores confronts Jerry and says she met
Jerry before he once came to the
west-world park and raped Dolores don't
you remember
Dolores says after everything we've
shared
that's just like what William says to
Dolores in season one but this time
Dolores is the powerful one and the
human is the helpless
Dolores knows all about Jerry because
last season she went to the forge which
records data on all the memories and DNA
and the minds of everyone who visits
Westworld so Dolores knows that Jerry
murdered his last wife she straps the
hologram glasses on to Jerry to project
images of his crime haunting him like
the ghost of Christmas past
Dolores steals money from Jerry and
takes Donna about a company called
insight which runs all the data tech in
the world
Dolores says that her goal is the origin
of a new species she wants the robot
hosts of Westworld to become their own
free people which means she'll have to
deal with humanity but Dolores says she
doesn't want to hurt anyone unless they
try to hurt her because Dolores has hurt
so many people already last season
Dolores killed lots of humans and hosts
who may have been innocent her brutality
drove her lover Teddy to suicide which
seems to have changed to lorises mind
she doesn't want to kill unless she has
to
so when Jerry tries to kill her she uses
a hologram in the glasses to trick Jerry
into dying in his pool she tells Jerry's
wife Eunice that she set her free from a
murderous husband so Dolores is no
longer just an evil murder bot taking
revenge on the entire human species now
she fights for justice and liberation
freeing not only hosts but oppressed
humans like eunice dolores takes a swim
in jerry's pool which could symbolize
washing away her past sins and starting
anew just like Teddy said the title of
this episode is passe dominum a Catholic
thing meaning spare Lord spare your
people be not angry with us forever
Dolores is less angry now she's more
merciful and just like a benevolent God
this could make Dolores a much more
sympathetic character than she was last
season in Los Angeles we meet Caleb he's
the first average person who have met in
this series all the park guests in past
seasons
rich tourists corporate types
technologists and sadists kaleb's just
an ordinary guy getting by in LA in 2058
he works in construction this shot
refers to a famous photo from 1930s New
York but Caleb works with a robot and
there's driverless cars and all the city
looks modern and clean and green Caleb
says technology has made some things
better but Caleb feels trapped his
mother is sick apparently with dementia
or something because she no longer
recognizes him and he can barely afford
her medical bills
so Caleb turns to crime and as an app
for that
it's called Rico and it's like uber or
TaskRabbit for crime its algorithm
offers jobs based on your location and
profile burglary delivery Grand Theft
Auto murder
everything's anonymous automatic
efficient and apparently untraceable
showrunner Jonathan Nolan says it works
on the blockchain like a Deep Web thing
and it's gamified you get points and
badges and crime coins and write people
on their performance which affects which
jobs you can get like star ratings in
uber so Rico is a parody of our
real-world algorithmic gig economy Caleb
does robberies and transport and stuff
but he chooses not to do personals
meaning he won't do murder and
kidnapping stuff so Caleb's an easily
likable character he only does crime to
pay for his mom's medical bills but
Caleb feels trapped in a loop these
shots of Caleb waking up each morning
are just like Dolores waking up in
season 1 Caleb takes a job robbing an
ATM like the hosts Hector Rob's the
saloon in season 1 Hector does the same
robbery over and over because his
programming tells him to just let Caleb
does these Rico jobs over and over
because it's algorithm tells him to
season 1 was about robots stuck in loops
and this season is about humans stuck in
loops controlled by code
Caleb meets with some criminal buddies
ash and giggles giggles is played by NFL
player Michonne Lynch and he's got a
sick mood that changes depending on how
he feels
ash has a device that blocks
surveillance and blasts Death Grips at
max volume
so this is a stylish cyberpunk dystopia
these guys barely scrape by but they
look fly while they do it the West world
parks are run by the Delos corporation
they have a meeting in the aftermath of
the massacre last season and it's run by
Charlotte Hale except we know that's not
really Charlotte last season Dolores
killed Charlotte and impersonated her
with Dolores brain in a Charlotte body
when Dolores left the park she created a
new Charlotte so whose brain is in there
now maybe it's one of these five host
brains that she took from the park it
can't just be Dolores cos we've seen
Dolores with this Charlotte last season
it's not Teddy because Dolores left him
behind in the sublime it's not Angelo
cause she blew up in the cradle it's not
Maeve or Bernard
maybe it could be Hector no of Damas
tiss oh there could be a twist like
maybe it's not a host at all but a copy
of a human like the James Delos clone or
it could be a totally new person like a
host child
whoever this charlotte is she's working
with Dolores to influence Delos she
takes the company private and says to
resume hosts production maybe Dolores
wants to keep making hosts so that her
new species can grow maybe she wants the
parks to keep running because she agrees
with Ford that hosts need to suffer in
the park before they can become
conscious like Dolores did to control
the board Charlotte needs approval from
another board member who isn't at the
meeting this must be William because
William owns Westworld he's the majority
shareholder but for years he's not come
to meetings preferring to spend his time
in the park he must have left this
machine shareholder to vote on stuff for
him and it agrees with Charlotte last
time we saw William he was alive in the
park but where is he now and does he
still control this machine maybe
Charlotte is hacking the machine like
Dolores hacks Jerry's home either way
Charlotte takes control and she blames
the whole Westworld massacre on Bernard
so Bernards on the run he's left his old
life behind for a simpler one like the
hound in Game of Thrones
with a very similar outfit Bernard works
on a farm and he finds an injured cow
with flies buzzing around it in season
two Dolores tells the story of some cows
getting an infection spread by flies
Teddy says he had protect and helped the
infected cows but Dolores says she'd
kill the wait cows so that the strong
cows can live so this continues the
theme of Mercy vs. survival passe
dominum should the weak died so that the
strong can survive should the weak
humans die so that the hosts can grow
and thrive
Bernard tries to help the hurt cow but
his human boss sends it for slaughter
just like humanity might be slaughtered
unless Dolores is merciful
inside the slaughterhouse humans butcher
animals just like the hosts were
butchered in the West World park in the
livestock section and then bernard talks
to himself in diagnostic mode he seems
to have two different personalities
there's the more human conscious side
and the more robotic unconscious side
they've talked to each other like Gollum
and Smeagol in Lord of the Rings
Bernard doesn't trust his Robo side he
questions whether he's been influenced
by Dolores because this Bernard was
created by Dolores last season maybe
Dolores left some backdoor or hack to
control Bernards subconscious mind
Bernards identity and mental state have
always been complicated Bernard is a
host based on a human called Arnold
Arnold Weber is an anagram of Bernard
Lowe now Bernard uses a fake identity
our mound Delgado which is an anagram
for damaged Arnold so Arman is an alias
of a copy of a copy of a dead man and
each time he's remade he's changed
rearranged like the letters of his name
so Bernard is all scrambled up and he's
struggling to figure out who he is he's
attacked by some workers who recognize
him as a fugitive so Bernard lets out
his Robo side which is a powerful
fighter
it's like Eddie Brock unleashing venom
Bernard says that he's trying to save
the human race from Dolores but they
don't listen so he's forced to
the people he's trying to help like that
cow so like in previous seasons Bernards
story is confusing but at least
everything seems to be happening within
one timeline again
Dolores goes to a fancy corporate event
for insight the tech company that runs
the world star de Dolores has seduced
the face of insight
Liam Dempsey and is using him to get
information on the company the party is
full of wealth and luxury and douchebags
Liam's friend brags that his drink is
worth more than people own in a year
meanwhile caleb can't afford his mom's
medical bills so this is a deeply
unequal society which is not so
different to reality showrunner Jonathan
Nolan says this is what the world might
be like if we continue the way we're
going with a small number of people
holding even more of the wealth and
power controlling everyone else through
technology
Liam's friend gets high and says nothing
is real we're all living in a simulation
man it is a common theory that the
so-called real world in this show is
actually another fake reality or another
park-like future world but the show
runners are clearly interested in
exploring our reality so having this guy
around about simulations might be their
way of dismissing the theory and saying
this is the real real world
dolorous says that a part of the brain
called the nucleus accumbens evolved to
make humans believe in God which is a
loose interpretation of the neuroscience
but there is evidence linking the
nucleus accumbens to religious
experiences so Dolores is point is that
believing the way inside someone's
simulation is basically the same as
believing the way in a world created by
a god either way you're just believing
in a higher power because that's what
our brains have evolved to believe
humans like robots can only follow their
code Dolores sees Rehoboam a computer
that processes all the data for the
inside corporation its algorithm gives
strategies that tell people how to live
what you should buy what job you should
work who you should date insite offers a
path for everyone in season one Dolores
believed in
path for everyone but then she realized
that was her programming trapping her in
a loop of suffering humans had been free
but now they've built technology that
traps them in loops as well
dolorous uses a six cyber bike and spy
glasses to listen in on a meeting
between Liam and an inside person called
Martel she says someone has been
accessing Rehoboam through Liam so this
probably means that Delores got in by
exploiting Liam's access Martel
threatens to use verbal arms daughter to
assassinate Liam so Liam admits to
Dolores that he has no real power at in
sight the only person who controls her
her Balam is its original architect a
mysterious guy called Zurich Liam
implies that Zurich may have murdered
Liam's father who was seracs business
partner
Dolores gets captured by Martin badass
fix a guy for Liam Martin figured out
that Dolores was using a fake identity
so Martin uses Rico to hire someone to
bring some drugs to kill Dolores and
Caleb gets the delivery job Martin
injects Dolores with the lethal drugs
bird they do nothing because she's a
robot
Dolores summons a driverless car and
inside is a host copy of Martin this
whole thing is Dolores as trap like with
Gerry she must have used Darla from the
forge to predict a manipulate Martin she
kills Martin and replaces him with the
host Martin loyal to her
so with this Martin and the Charlotte
Dolores is using hosts to infiltrate
powerful tech companies to take over the
human world and help the birth of a new
host species Martin's men attack and
they have a shootout in MacArthur Park
Dolores goes all Terminator on their
asses as a robot she's fast and tough
but she is not invulnerable she walks
wounded into a tunnel where she's found
by Caleb Caleb was once in the army with
his friend Francis played by a kid cudi
but something went wrong Francis got
killed and caleb is traumatized the army
put him in a psych program but instead
of a human therapist he has to talk to a
chat bot with the voice and personality
of his dead friend like some black
Mira [ __ ] and this Francis bought isn't
like the real Francis the bought
encourages compliance with the system
and playing the game when the real
Francis was rebellious
so Caleb rejects the bot and says he
needs someone real and that's when he
meets Dolores so the irony will be that
the robot Dolores is the realest person
in Caleb's life unlike everyone else
who's trapped in a loop
Dolores follows her own plan in season 1
Dolores fell into the arms of William
who became the man in black William
taught her that humans are selfish and
cruel maybe Caleb will show Dolores that
humans can be good and selfless Sharon a
Jonathan Nolan says Caleb represents
humaneness and humility and kindness but
Caleb is still mysterious he casually
mentions that he's been shot in the head
before and his mother did say that he's
not her son so there are theories that
Caleb is actually some robot replacement
though that could undermine the whole
human good idea though I've still got a
question whether this meeting of Dolores
and Caleb really is random chance Caleb
was brought to Dolores by a job on the
Ricoh app Rico is meant to be
untrackable but it'd be a cool twist if
the crime app was actually controlled by
insight the easiest way to prevent
rebellion is to make rebellion part of
the system right like in the matrix when
the one and Xion are actually programmed
by the machines or like the prison
industry in the real world throughout
the episode we get these shots where
some system sees divergence and
anomalies in the places where Dolores
and Caleb go maybe this is Rehoboam
seeing Dolores and Caleb as flickers in
the world's data maybe CEREC who
controls rovol arm deliberately brings
Caleb and Dolores together for some
higher plan at the very least insight is
[ __ ] with Caleb he interviews to get
a better job but gets rejected by a
company's strategy group Rehoboam
thoughts are called strategies so it
seems like incites Dada is preventing
him from getting hired
maybe because Rehoboam is aware of his
criminal activity on Rico or is
listening to ease
anti-authority attitudes in his calls
with the Frances boss or maybe it's some
other arbitrary thing the point is that
through data technology humanity has
handed its freedom away to machines so
even outside the west-world Park we
can't be sure who's in control and
what's a real Bernard
takes a boat to the West World parks his
map seems to confirm that West world is
on an island in the South China Sea
Bernard says he's looking for a friend
and offer the credits we see the friend
he's looking for Maeve wakes up in an
unfamiliar place last season she
sacrificed herself to save her daughter
the teks Felix and Sylvester were told
to salvage her and it looks like they've
put her in a new park war world a
simulation of Italy in the Second World
War Bernards goal is apparently to get
Maeve's help to stop Dolores from
destroying humanity
so maybe Maeve will finally leave West
world and see the real world for the
first time in season one Maeve's
programmed narrative said that she
crossed the shining sea to a new world
where she can be whoever the [ __ ] she
wants now she'll finally get to do that
for real
but first she'll probably kill some
Nazis Westworld has a new intro sequence
that highlights some of the themes of
the season there's a dandelion with its
florets traced by geometric lines like
how the natural world follows
mathematical laws and the human mind can
be described with lines of code there's
an eagle flying into a jet engine like
Icarus at the Sun like how Humanity is
destroying itself in the pursuit of
technology but the main imagery is of
reflection repetitions and symmetry
season 1 was about hosts controlled by
code season 3 is about humans controlled
by code Delores was powerless against
humans now she's the powerful one she
meets Caleb as she met William but not
worked on host livestock now he works on
animal life stock images lines and
phrases are repeated and refracted in
different situations this is even
reflected in the architecture all this
glass mirrors and water
this shot also resembles the famous
painting of the Creation of Adam which
appeared in season one we see dividing
cells because Dolores wants the birth
and growth of a new host species so
there is some optimism in the new intro
but the intro ends with the logo in
bright red hinting that despite all the
changes Westworld remains a bloody
affair with violent delights and violent
ends the intro also shows Bravo Balaam
because this season is all about data
and algorithms controlling humanity this
might sound like a sci-fi idea but big
tech has been using data to predict and
control us for years and you can read
all about this in the Age of
surveillance capitalism by Shoshana
Zubov it's a deep exploration of the
systems that increasingly control our
lives it's at least as scary as anything
in Westworld and it's real you can get
it on audiobook for free right now by
signing up for trial with audible
members get an audiobook each month and
if you cancel you keep the audiobooks
you can listen in your driverless car or
on your cyber bike sign up at
audible.com slash ASX remember to like
and subscribe and press the bell
otherwise the algorithm might not show
you our videos
we're holding live streams right after
each episode of Westworld season 3 at
about 10:30 p.m. Eastern Time Sundays
patreon supporters can watch live
streams after the broadcast
thanks to patrons Noland Strout the band
of Goro hazard al Sony Ben Katz Tania
Travis Helen Quest and drug dog Cheers
you